what I love doing is I want to teach
myself I want to inoculate myself
against judgment I want to teach myself
that if my heart's beaten but it's a
sign that I need to go do the thing most
of the things that we're afraid of doing
are because of other people's opinions
you're playing small because you're
worried how somebody's going to judge
you you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing in the street corner you
record a video but you won't post it on
YouTube you want to do great things but
you're afraid of the reaction that's
going to happen if you can feel that
then it's man I don't want to live my
whole life plain small because of
somebody else's opinion on me now we've
got entrepreneurs who are watching
entrepreneurs we want to do different
things we want to change the status quo
there's a lot of people who want to
protect the status quo all those people
who want to protect the status quo they
won't like you by default just because
of what you represent without knowing
you you're taking stuff away from them
they don't like that so they hate you
just by definition right so if you want
to go off and have a huge impact you're
going to get the bigger impact you want
the more people are going to line up
against you who want to protect what
currently is and so if you can't do
something as simple as ask a girl out or
sing on the street or something simple
then you're never going to do the big
thing me motivation watch your top 10 We
Believe Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael
and we made these videos probably
because you're the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of more and you need to push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband Evan Carmichael and our take on
his top 10 rules for Success enjoy
rule number two love what you do I feel
like what I do matters
I think I think that's really really
important I think people are starting
the business only trying to make money
often burn out and and don't make money
I've been doing YouTube for 12 years now
we've done over 10 000 videos not all of
them are public and people ask me well
how do you keep going like how do you
not burn out how do you stay consistent
we haven't missed a day of uploading
video in maybe 70 years something like
that something crazy
uh well how because
I love what I'm doing because I feel
like it matters because this isn't it
look at this interview here with Michael
is this work this doesn't feel like work
for me this is fun
this is a holiday in Canada for me right
now this is our Independence Day right
now we're filming this on Canada
Independence Day right now and I'm here
talking with Michael because it's fun
right and so when you're doing work that
you love and you feel is having an
impact it's a lot easier to stay
positive and excited and have momentum
where if you're forcing yourself to do
something that you hate because you
think it's going to make you money
that's when you start diving on the path
of boredom and maybe ultimately
depression rule number three do scary
things the number one thing you can do
for your confidence is to do scary
things when you come up against
something that's scary that's difficult
that's hard and you don't do them you're
telling yourself that you can't and that
you suck you're teaching yourself with
every inaction that you're the kind of
person who plays small you need to flip
that thinking it's scary you do it it's
scary you're jumping because you do
scary things you want to be scared if
you have things that make you scared it
means you're growing you're learning
you're getting better if there's nothing
in your calendar that makes you scared
in the next month you hate your life
that's actually most people most people
don't have anything in their calendar
that is scary and they look at their
calendar head and they hate their life
they're bored they're photocopying the
same day over and over again you don't
want that so the goal isn't to not be
scared because that means you're playing
small the goal is to find things that
are scary and that to teach yourself
that you do them rule number four find a
way to serve people I think 99.99 of
people are built to serve I think I
think we get we get Happiness by helping
other people with what we can help them
with I think there's a tiny tiny
percentage of people who who enjoy
killing people the gut brain chemicals
kind of messed up but most people aren't
like that right thankfully we wouldn't
be here in general we want to like I
think of your greatest moments they
involve somebody else thinking your
happiest most proud moments of all time
they involve somebody else you've helped
the the the winning for you the Great
Moments won't just be receiving some
check or making a lot of money it's like
how are you going to use that to help
somebody else so so we're wired to serve
just not everybody's wired to serve the
world so you have to understand your
style for people watching this show
they're probably where I have to serve
the world entrepreneurs we want to make
a big impact a big change a big
difference yeah but not everybody's
built that way some people just they
want to serve the closest people friends
family you know my wife is still in
touch with people from her grade one in
China you know like she keeps in touch
with people like
she's a master networker I guess too but
I don't um I don't I don't care that
much about
about people like that I want to help
the world there was a really interesting
question that somebody asked me uh like
would you rather would I rather have a
hundred thousand people really
understand my message and get it
or or my son
and I picked a hundred thousand people
wow
and my wife this wasn't wasn't happy
right now I don't know what no no she
wasn't not happy she gets it but but it
but it's just a different approach now
where does the I don't know how what's
the number is it is it one thousand is
it five thousand I don't want to go down
that slippery but that idea of you know
ultimately if my wife really needed
something
from me I would be there for her but but
at the end of the day I need to be free
to be doing the work that I love doing
yeah and so you you have to find a way
to serve also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five build a great team I
did everything myself at the beginning I
had I was doing one video per week on
YouTube and then the first hire I had
was an editor and that let me go to one
video a day instead of just one video a
week and so the sooner you can start to
incorporate people in your life who can
support you either emotional support you
know Nina my wife now is involved in my
business is my chief heart officer and
does a lot of work inside the company
but at the beginning she she didn't know
anything about YouTube besides watching
she didn't give me any advice she really
know what to do but just supporting me
just encouraging me just understanding
me that that's a big it makes a big
difference when you have somebody in
your life who's just there for you and
understands you even if they can't give
you practical knowledge just that
support is helpful but then also the
people who can actually do the thing
that you need help with even if it's for
one hour a week or one hour a day like
that first person I hired was one hour a
day and that saved one and a half to two
hours a day of my time because he was
better at the thing than I was so you
don't need to have a big budget to go
hire somebody but if you have a big
mission then you have to realize that
ultimately you can't do this alone and
make a commitment that by the end of
next month you're going to have somebody
else on your team helping you we often
get inspired whether it's watching a
video like this doing you know hearing
an interview from Michael or somebody
else reading a book how many times
you've read a book and been inspired but
then you don't do anything
and we say okay tomorrow we're going to
do it and the next week we're going to
do it and then nothing ends up happening
so if you got inspired by this you took
any idea from this
the best thing you can do is today take
one small piece of action towards it if
your goal is I want to be a YouTuber as
well great the best thing you can do is
make a video
if your goal is to write your own book
great the best thing you do right now is
write the first page of content
and expect it to suck
just expect it to suck your first page
is gonna suck your first video is
definitely going to suck it doesn't mean
you suck as a human it just means you
don't have the skill set yet why would
you have the skill set if it's your
first time doing it
so just expect to suck but get started
because that's the thing that most
people Miss there's a lot of smart
people who consume a lot of content who
can who can say what I'm gonna say
before I say it because they've seen so
much of it and I've read so many books
thousands of books and had them
memorized but then they're still stuck
in life
because you're not taking the action
so the most important thing you can do
when you're reading a book at least I
think when you're reading a book when
you're watching a video go pause it put
the book down for a second pause the
video and then go take some immediate
action from it if you look at all those
books on Michael's shelf behind you if
you all have that collection and in each
one of those books you actually took
just one idea away from it and did
something about it your life will be
dramatically different
so the message is do something today do
something today to get some momentum on
your big goal rule number seven start
getting paid you could see the end
picture and the goal and the vision
you've got for yourself and what you
want to make but
from where you are now to where you're
gonna be it just feels too too big too
slow too impossible needing Venture
Capital funding needing a whole ton of
support like no you just need to figure
out what's the next step that will start
to pay you for what you're doing this is
where people often don't want to have
the conversation because they just want
to do everything for free
like but that's great but you have to
you have to make money doing this
so that you can make this your full-time
thing so you can hire a team so you can
expand so you can have a bigger reach
you can have a much bigger impact so you
can actually create the world that you
want to create again money is not number
one but you have to figure out a way to
make money so inside of your big dream
what is the next step that you have to
take that's going to start to get you
paid
and often it's coaching often it's
selling your time right often it's
taking the expertise that you have
inside you you solved the problem for
yourself now you're going to help other
people do it you're gonna get paid to do
it rule number eight Embrace fear I'm
very much the kind of the same way that
you are in terms of that's the biggest
fear for me is knowing like thinking
about myself getting to the end of my
life and then just wishing that I had
done this or done that or taken that
chance that one it's because it's a slow
bleed
hmm
can you explain what you mean by that
yeah because that regret is something
that's going to happen every day for the
next X number of years of your life like
from from now if I'm 39 to 99 that's 60
years of my life right but it's going to
be a little bit of pain every day versus
doing it and failing is massive pain
yeah and so on a daily that massive pain
of failure is bigger than the little bit
of pain of regret but if you accumulate
all those days of regret and then bring
it back to today it actually ends up
being way bigger but people don't feel
it because you just see this massive
pain and you'll pick the one you don't
want to do that massive pain right
people won't do that and so I try to
make I try to imagine myself at 99 in my
rocking chair now it's over like I can't
do it I don't have the energy I can't
chase that down my mind is going and and
now that's Decades of regret and I try
to make it more painful right right to
live in that pain moment yes and bring
it back to today so if you have a hang
nail it's going to hurt you but then if
somebody punches you in the arm you
forget about the hangnail yeah right and
so what I want to do is punch myself in
the arm with regret make it more painful
so then I don't feel this thing
and so I don't think you can be Fearless
I just give myself a greater fear right
that thing is scary failing is failing
it is scary right that asking her out or
your business tanking or whatever that's
real that's a that's a fear yeah and I
just want to give myself a bigger fear
to force me into action remember that
creating the environment for yourself
for Success so
you know if if best book bits inspires
you great look at the content every day
if this show inspires you great follow
Michael and look at the other stuff that
he's doing most of us don't have enough
people around us who are doing amazing
things chances are the people listening
to this show you're the most
ambitious person that you know
you're the most growth oriented you're
the one pouring in other people you're
the one saying this book I just read you
have to go read it
and we're
fliss on other people because we've
learned so much you've learned so much
and you just want to share with other
people but the people around you aren't
as receptive aren't as open aren't as
growth minded as you are and and that's
a great gift that you're giving them but
the challenge is you don't have people
who are pushing you and so I try to
surround myself with with the
environment that pushes me forward in
the content that I make because I want
to be around Oprah Winfrey and Elon Musk
and super successful entrepreneurs
because they because they pulled me
forward and so the more that I'm around
that the more I want to believe in
myself and go chase my dreams so that's
the first like your environment your
habits your routine are you around the
people who are lifting you up either in
person but more likely online or through
books that inspire you as part of your
daily routine not just a one-off thing
that you happen to do rule number ten
the last one before our very special
bonus clip stop overthinking things when
it's simple you can go fast when it's
simple when you have Clarity when you've
got Direction that's so much easier to
get stuff done to actually make progress
on your goals but when you're stuck with
over complicating overthinking over
strategizing nothing happens you felt
this you've had ideas you've had goals I
have too dreams goals Ambitions desires
like here's what I want to do and then
what do we do what's the next step we
make it so big we start thinking of all
the possibilities of where it could go
and what could go wrong and we start
planning and overthinking and
researching and more planning and more
research and more and then as a result
nothing happens nothing happens because
we've now wasted days of just research
planning thinking and we've made it so
big that we feel like we can't do it by
ourselves anymore like now now we can't
get started because we need a team we
need money we need investors we need
promotion we need people to help us we
need we need we need we need all these
things we never actually make if you've
been there I lost a 40 million deal when
I was 20 because of that
because of overthinking over planning
over preparing and not enough doing and
it's not that planning isn't important
it's just not the first step the first
step is to get really clear really
narrow really specific to this is what I
need to do and then going off and doing
it because you have time
we feel like we don't have time even if
you have a job you have family you have
time the problem is the time that you're
spending on your business is not
intentional enough is not simple enough
it's not clear enough and you spend your
time going in circles overthinking
instead of actually doing does that
sound familiar
you go as far as you believe you can go
when the people around you say you're
crazy when you're putting in massive
effort but you're not getting the
results where you sit alone and wonder
did you just make the biggest mistake of
your life by starting this business that
is the time when most people quit and
you need to believe more because if you
love this thing if you know that it's
going to impact people and you give up
too soon you will regret for the rest of
your life knowing that you were capable
of more and you just quit on it a little
too early so I look at my new book as an
example I did my tour Across America met
with entrepreneurs all across America
and found that people were struggling
with the same thing they want to know
how do I find what my purpose is and
turn it into a lucrative business every
city that I went to even though that was
not the topic I was covering it came up
over and over and over and over again 23
different cities and so I thought I'm
going to write a book on this this is
going to be my next book I'm going to
take people to the process because my
process works and it helps people live
in in 10 15 minutes and they're getting
they're getting new ideas and and
results and here we go like they
understand what path they need to take
finally they have Clarity on what to do
next and so I told my agent and my lit
agent like this is the next book I want
to write
[Music]
Publishers this is the next book I'm
going to write
and from the start it's been
it's been fighting it's we don't like
the title we don't like the concept no
we're not going to publish it no we're
not going to publish it and I want to do
it by January because I want to do my
next tour across the rest of the United
States East Coast Texas Mexico I want to
do my next tour so I want to have my
book in stores by that time and it's
been this rough slog where if I didn't
believe in myself that this was so
important with the people who are
looking at it saying nah we don't like
this concept now it's been written
before now this method we don't believe
in
it's easy to quit it's easy to give up
it's easy to say forget it I just know
that it's gonna work
I know that the process helps people
I've seen it with my eyes across 23
cities over 90 days
I wrote the draft of the book and I gave
it to some beta readers and the number
one piece of advice from people who've
read both my books the year one word and
then this like this is this is the
better book this is the best book you've
written so far including my
self-published ones and so what do I do
I've got these people who are my
audience who love it and then these
people who aren't my audience but who
make decisions saying now we don't
believe in it
I'm not gonna call it
comment I gotta keep going I gotta do my
tour
there's there better be some crazy good
reason for me not to do my tour right
even if I have to self-publish it now
I'm pretty close at making my deal
making it all happen and and getting
timelines and all that but we don't have
a signed contract yet and anything can
happen
we're pushing the timelines because I'm
pushing the timelines because otherwise
this thing could drag on forever when
you have an idea that you love that you
know can have a huge impact
that's just taking longer than you hoped
it would when people are telling you
that it's crazy and that it's stupid and
that who are you to go off and do this
thing
you love it you have to double down on
me you have to go in on it you have to
be open to getting help but if that door
closes you try to find another one and
that's the story of every successful
person you're trying to do something
different as long as you love it you
have to keep going you cannot quit maybe
one day somebody does throw you a bunch
of money and you can stop sleeping in
your office or maybe it's just a slow
grind up and it takes you 10 years to
become an overnight success you'll never
know how long it will take you to be
successful but what you do know is that
if you quit on something that you love
you will end up regretting it for the
rest of your life as long as you love it
you have to keep going you can't quit so
look at my story it wasn't easy being an
entrepreneur growing up that's why I do
so much to help entrepreneurs because I
don't want you guys to struggle as much
as I did in my first real business when
I was 19 I had to decide between earning
a hundred thousand dollars a year and
travel around the world in my dream job
versus owning thirty percent of a
company making 300 bucks a month and
being unsure if anything is going to
work out or not and I decided that I had
to keep going I had to try because I
didn't want to end up being 85 years old
looking back and said I never did it I
never went for it I would rather no one
fail than not know because the things
that you regret are rarely the things
that you do it's the things that you
didn't do the things that you had a
chance to do you had an opportunity you
thought about it you felt it but then
you back down because you're afraid
those are the things that you regret
that's what you regret most I didn't
want that to happen
but starting off my business wasn't easy
I struggled I suck I made it harder on
myself because I told my friends that I
was living the entrepreneur life and I
couldn't hang out with them meanwhile
that twenty dollars was just too
expensive for me to go out and have beer
with them
I sell it to myself and made myself
lonely
I felt worthless as a human being and
the worst day of my life came when I
told my business partner that I quit on
him that it was just too difficult that
I couldn't keep going that I needed to
feel like I was contributing that that
my time meant something that all this
work I was putting into something I just
need to feel valuable again that I was
contributing to something because when
you wake up every day and you're working
and it's just not getting results it can
be real hard to keep going
and so I told him that I quit I hung up
the phone and then just started crying
and the next day I woke up and I just
thought I can't I can't I can't quit on
this not yet I haven't given everything
I've got
because I felt like
in a year and two years and five years
and 20 years I would look back and
regret that I gave up
if I knew that I gave everything I had
and it didn't work out I was okay with
the failure
it was just an idea of that thing
lingering that I could have given a
little bit more that I still like this
thing and I needed to see it through and
I and I didn't that I quit on it I knew
that would eat me up forever
and so I had to get up that next day and
tell myself I'm not going to quit yet I
just have to find a different way to
stand what I've tried so far has not
worked it has not worked I'm making zero
money well 300 bucks a month
but it's not working out and I hate
myself I hate my life
I hate how I feel about myself I have to
find a different way to stand
and that energy allowed me to keep going
that energy allowed me to then ask
myself who else has done this before and
I looked at Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that started the
path up for my business and then two
years later I sold my company it
happened pretty quick
all because I refuse to quit on the
thing that I knew I needed to see
through people aren't afraid of failing
you're afraid of failing in front of
other people you'll sing in the shower
but you won't sing on the street corner
you'll record a video but you'll never
release it you'll be your own biggest
critic but you won't at the same time
also be your own biggest fan that needs
to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too even just attacking it
for the sake of attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur because
that's the same fear that you face in
your business that fear of going on that
game show on the cruise ship that fear
of taking your phone and recording a
video in public on the street these
fears that seem like nothing they show
up everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
but instead of being world class at that
thing you settled for being just above
average at something that you should not
be doing Albert Einstein once said
everybody is a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb a tree it
will believe its whole life that it is
stupid that's most people's problems you
are a fish
and you're trying to climb a tree
instead of going and being great at
swimming this is the exact problem that
I am on a mission to solve so I recently
had a young entrepreneur come to one of
my Toronto q a meetups that are free
that I host every week and he said Evan
I have a problem I'm trying to decide
between what my parents want me to be
which is an architect and what I feel uh
yearning towards which is being a
musician and I don't know what to do
know how to decide I don't know how I'm
going to be a success as a musician I
don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly defined
path for how to do it and he's afraid
I think that's so many people there's a
safe perfect path that has been designed
that people have done forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever or this is
new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it it's never been easier to
actually be yourself and build a
business and have success being uniquely
you right this was not open to your
parents and definitely not your
grandparents the ability to be an
entrepreneur on the side making money
using your phone is something that your
grandparents don't understand it's just
it's totally wild and so you are a
unique individual right you are I am we
all are you have unique interests
personality traits belief systems you're
unique you need to do something unique
if you are unique you need to do
something unique if you're stuck doing
the same thing that somebody else wants
you to do you're never going to be happy
now there may be some alignment you may
not absolutely hate the job that you're
at but you know you're capable of more
you're Michael Jordan you are the
Michael Jordan of something you're a
genius and absolute bona fide genius at
something this is why I think it's the
world's greatest problem this is why I
do what I do every single day in making
this content videos for you because I
want to unlock people hope hopefully
more than one at a time but even if it's
just one person who watches this video
and gets unlocked I'm pumped because I
think if everybody is off doing the
thing that they are a genius at man I
want to live in that world you haven't
become a shark yet because you haven't
decided that your mission is important
enough now being a shark doesn't mean
that you have to become aggressive
violent and angry it means that you're
pushing to be the best in your industry
a true leader someone who makes a
difference and it starts with your
mission raise the level of how important
your mission feels to you and your
entire life changes so I look at my
mission as an example I want to solve
the world's biggest problem it's never
going to happen I'm trying to solve the
biggest problem I think in the world
which is that lack of belief in yourself
the untapped potential that's what I
wake up every day trying to do and the
more that I put myself in a position of
this thing matters what I do really
really matters the more I can put myself
in that mind frame the bigger my
thinking becomes the Bolder I get as a
human and as an entrepreneur and I look
at the path that I've taken over the
past X number of years I look at being
able to collaborate with someone like
Eric Thomas when he gave a shout out in
his video that would have been something
I wouldn't have thought of when I first
started on YouTube I look at the
relationships I built with people like
Tony Robbins and Gary vaynerchuk and
Grant Cardone and the people that we
profile Tony Robbins I took the people
on my team to go see him at Unleash the
Power Within I brought five I think of
my people down and we're sitting up in
the cheap seats and then a year later a
year later he invited me as his personal
guest to sit right down in the front row
chairman invited seating and I'm going
back I leave tomorrow I don't know when
this video goes up but I leave tomorrow
for Dallas to do it again
it's wild
right like it doesn't feel like that
stuff is possible
it comes from shift in the value of your
your mission I deserve it because what
I'm doing is solving a real problem
and we often feel like we're not capable
of doing these great things and we
downplay our role and we downplay how
important our mission is and we downplay
what we think we can do that's what
needs to shift that's what needs to
change you need to feel like the work
you do matters you need to feel like the
mission you're on means something can
have a big impact and if you're
approaching life in that way everything
in your business changes your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you exactly where you are the
people you hang with the videos you
watch the midi you consume all of it are
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now today if you
want to raise your standards it starts
by raising your environment first so a
friend of mine and friend of the channel
Mark Drager from Fanta gave me a really
warm message yesterday and he thanked me
for helping start the process for him to
turn from being a pessimist to an
optimist from being somebody who was
always worried and negative to somebody
who's having more energy who's seen the
light who's being becoming more
optimistic who still has a road to go
but it's so far further long than where
he was before and he wrote to me to say
thank you for starting me down this path
he said there was one conversation in
particular that had special meaning to
him where I told them that I I just
really believed in him that I saw a lot
of the people around him I saw a lot of
his peers and I just thought that he had
so much more potential than where he was
and I think maybe for the first time he
had an extra bolt of belief pushed into
him which is what I do which is what I'm
great at which is what I enjoy doing
fast forward to now six months eight
months later he's made major gains in
his life he's he's brought on new team
members he's now consuming other content
that is positive and optimistic he's
changing his business around he's
investing more in himself he's happier
he's lost a lot of weight he's he's
growing he's wanting to strengthen his
relationships he's just seen a big shift
in his life by trying to move more into
opt optimism instead of pessimism and so
it started with my conversation with him
he then promoted somebody within his
organization to become CEO whose name
was Louis and he's also a massive Force
for good and positivity he started
consuming Gary's content which is
positivity he started consuming Tom
Billy's content which is positivity he
started now injecting all these these
people and resources into his life to
make him feel more positive more
optimistic more happy give him more
energy so that he has that to go take on
his goals and the challenges are in
front of him and slowly move that needle
from being a pessimist to an optimist I
don't think people are pessimists to be
honest I think everybody is born an
optimist I don't think people are born
negative you know I think that's trained
into you I think you're pessimists and
negative because of the circumstances
you had and what was planted in your
brain by the people around you I think
people are good I think humans are just
good I think if we weren't good we
wouldn't be here anymore
99.9999 of people are good right some
people have a little bit of a miswiring
up there and it causes them to enjoy
killing people but for the most part
we're good I also believe that people
are built to serve
I believe that you get happiness from
helping others by being of service to
others that's what actually makes you
happy there aren't very many happy
moments in your life that involve
somebody else you're helping you're
serving
they've shown the effect on your brain
of serving and helping somebody is the
same as food and sex we're literally
hardwired to help others and to serve
and so if you believe like I believe
that humans are good and humans are
built to serve then what would cause
somebody to be pessimistic and negative
how sad of an upbringing does that
person have to have had the programming
that was installed inside them by other
people who just were negative and down
on their life but weren't inherently bad
people the people who stole from my car
in La the guy who cut me off in traffic
yesterday I don't think they're bad
people I still think they're good people
who are built to serve just
circumstances and conditioning have led
them down a negative path and so the
good news is you can get out of it just
like my friend Mark has someone who
would who was sworn to say I am a
pessimist
right I just default to negativity
to now seeing the shift
by changing the people he surrounded
himself with by altering his environment
by consuming content that is more
positive he has already seen a
noticeable shift with a past X number of
months and that's going to continue to
grow
that can be YouTube most people quit on
things because they don't have a
powerful Mission or they don't know
where their Drive comes from chasing an
opportunity isn't enough because you're
going up against people who love that
thing who might be willing to die for
that thing if you want to go to Mars
you're competing against Elon Musk who
would die to go to Mars you better
absolutely love it or he's going to
crush you you need to find the thing
that you love that does not feel like
work otherwise you'll end up working
your entire life and hating it so every
Thursday when I'm in Toronto I do this
free event for Toronto entrepreneurs at
my dance studio Toronto dance salsa five
to six pm Thursdays when I'm in the city
I do a free event q a session for an
hour come out meet me talk let's hang
out however I can help give back to the
community and help local entrepreneurs
my Thursdays are Bonkers my Thursdays
are all day long interviews Hangouts
podcasts Skype sessions one-on-ones my
assistant books them in 25 minute chunks
and I have 25 minutes on five minute
break in between usually I use that
break to get set up for the next one 25
minutes 5 25 5 25 5 the whole day long
and then I end up going to the studio I
record my podcast with Mark Drager I
then do two 30 minute one-on-ones that
we filmed for the YouTube channel and
then after all of that I do a one hour q
a for the entrepreneur community and
then after that I'm doing more meetings
with my team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
Thursday how do you have the energy for
all of that stuff
I love it like I I love being there with
the people that group session is the
best for me I love it I'm not getting
paid for it it's free it's probably not
a great use of my time if I had to pick
for one hour what's the best use of my
time hang out with startup entrepreneurs
ask me their questions or or do
something like write my book or make my
next course or something else it
probably doesn't make the most sense but
I love it and so therefore it makes the
most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be torture and it
should be for me to jump into your
schedule should be torture I should look
at your calendar and say that's
ridiculous how do you have so much
energy for all that stuff and when you
jump in the mind and you look the exact
same for me when I gear up for Thursday
as an example when I put my extrovert
hat on I gain energy as the day goes on
I'm not losing energy by the time I hit
five o'clock and I'm doing the group
session with people I'm carrying the
energy of all the entrepreneurs that
I've met on my 25 minute one-on-ones
throughout the entire day
I love it I gain more steam but most
things ask me to do almost anything else
for for 8 10 12 14 hours I would hate my
life Aspen to make coffee for for 10
hours a day I would hate my life ask me
to play piano ask me to do almost
anything for that amount of time I would
hate my life because it feels like work
and so you have to find the thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it it actually gives you
energy so paying attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh
oh this sucks like that's a good signal
that you're doing the wrong thing
because you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are a genius you
should be crushing it at something and
if the work that you're doing is
draining your energy the people around
you are draining your energy chances are
you're in the wrong spot you're hanging
them with the wrong people you're doing
the wrong kind of work everything in
your life changes when you learn to tie
your self-worth to your effort instead
of the results most people tie their
software to the results to winning you
only feel good about yourself when you
win if that's how you think then you're
screwed because that person only takes
on projects that you know you have a
pretty high chance of winning at and
therefore you play small for Life the
key is to tie yourself Worth to the
effort to trying and if you do that well
you'll win Beyond Your Wildest
imaginations so let's use me as an
example look at this video right here
this video two minutes before getting on
and making this video I'm nervous
I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why
I've done 6 000 of these videos do I not
love it anymore nope that's not it I
love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through I put this
pressure on myself to say this video
right now has to be the best video that
I've ever made that's my intention going
in to every time I'm filming most days I
don't accomplish it when you're trying
something new and scary and bigger and
Bolder most the time you won't get it
you fail a lot
but I tie my self-worth my respect to
the effort I'm trying and every now and
then you'll make a bit of a breakthrough
you get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another win and
another win and so the answer isn't have
a big goal and then find a reason why
you can't do it the answer isn't dream
big and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
abilities to get up and try again and
try again and try again and pat yourself
on the back for the effort you're
putting in not just when you're winning
self-esteem comes from doing difficult
things you set a goal you said you'd
start doing something and maybe even you
do actually start doing that thing but
then you hit a roadblock then it gets
difficult it gets hard and what you do
in that moment will Define the rest of
your life when it's hard when it's
difficult do you rise to the occasion or
do you let yourself off again finding
some really logical reason why you can't
do that thing it doesn't count until
it's hard you don't grow until it's hard
you don't build self-respect self-esteem
self-confidence until it's hard and you
follow through I keep these in my office
as a reminder of who I am of who I am in
my best moments my best self to push me
to do more to push harder what what are
these if you're new to my channel
welcome I'm Evan uh I went on a tour at
the beginning of this year I did a tour
of 23 cities 90 days and two-thirds of
the way through with a month left I
broke my neck when I was in Denver I
fainted I fell out of the chair I hit my
head against the wall cracked my the
back of my head open I had three Staples
on my head I had a concussion and I
broke my neck in two spots
and after that night I had to wear this
I had to wear this for the next
I just noticed this note here Nina
signed it
I love you get well soon Nina she signed
it that's that's sweet
oh
gotta go thank her
[Music]
decided to keep going on my tour I had a
month left everybody was telling me to
go home my agent told me to go home my
friends my family said come home get get
the health care you need relax stay in
bed rest you need to recover and I said
being with entrepreneurs is my recovery
and pushing through and doing this tour
is my healing one physical healing
because just sitting on the bed all day
is not going to be for someone like me
uh something that's amazing but two just
just push it through and knowing that I
can right it doesn't count until it's
hard it doesn't count until it's
difficult and then you get up and you do
it and so if you've seen any of the
videos or pictures of me at the events I
went from
standing up and moving around and having
energy to then I had to sit at the front
of a room with pillows behind me and an
ice pack on my shoulder blade for three
and a half four hours in massive pain
the whole time answering questions and
doing my workshop and I was so proud of
myself for doing it that's how I built
my self-esteem by getting up and doing
it by showing up
and it inspired the people who came out
they're saying well I you know I live 25
minutes away didn't know if I wanted to
make the drive if I commit to it I was
kind of tired and then I saw you with
your broken neck still showing up so I
had to show up too
right but that's not why I did it I did
it for me I did it for myself I had to
wear this all day all night long this
was my first one and then it started to
break so Nina put some duct tape on it
here and then this this was my second
one that once it started to really wind
down I couldn't wear it anymore I went
for this one and 10 minutes a day is all
I could do to take it off for a shower
so I had to sleep in this I had to do my
workshop in this everything
23 hours and 50 minutes a day except for
a 10 minute break in the shower where I
took it off and was paranoid about
moving anything because my neck was
broken I had to keep it stabilized I
wore these
this reminds me of how strong I am as
time has gone on I've become less and
less a fan of goal setting
and I love the idea of quarterly goals
over annual goals over decade-long goals
because the timeline is shorter and why
I'm less a fan of goal setting is
because
the more you're actually growing
the less likely you're actually able to
predict where you're going to be
so I really hate 10-year goals five-year
goals 10-year goals if you think about
where you were five years ago think
about who you were five years ago
five years ago look at the calendar five
years ago from today
in the past who are you
you think that person could predict
where you would be
ten years ago
ten years ago I just started my YouTube
channel
I had a couple videos up 10 years ago I
said I'd never want to write a book ten
years ago I wouldn't imagine that I'd be
here I'd be here
making videos for a YouTube channel with
300 million views in Puerto Rico because
Brendan Bouchard invited me to his
Mastermind group
speak on stage in front of all these
successful entrepreneurs I wouldn't have
predicted that like with with zero
accuracy
and same thing for you ten years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing and this is the big
caveat not if you're growing like if you
can predict with accuracy where you're
gonna be in 10 years
you can hit it but it's just way
compared to what you could have done and
it means that you haven't grown in the
past decade
and so that's my main beef against bulls
and and
having shorter goals having numericals
can be great can be great like I want to
get 10 million subscribers on my main
YouTube channel that's a good goal
but if I set that as my 10-year goal and
that's the only thing I'm gonna do then
it's wrong because probably in three
years I should jump off and go do
something else right I've been fortunate
that I've been doing YouTube for 10
years and I I still love it it's still
amazing but Jenkins are your 10-year
plans you should jump off in year two
and go through something else because
that thing is actually better for you
because you've grown as a person
so at least that's great the advice that
instead of annual goals send it down to
quarterly goals because goals are still
helpful
they're so good to kind of track your
progress to know that this video did
better than that video that this
customer brought in more money than this
customer that are you doing enough
action to go and get the business that
you want
those are great
but as a macro thing that's leading your
decisions
I think the longer you stretch it out
the worse it actually is chasing down
your dream is scary chances are nobody
around you has done anything close to
what you want to do and they don't
understand you they think you're crazy
well you know what here's the news flash
you are crazy and you need to embrace
your crazy ideas right now all your
regret for the rest of your life that
you never took action so I'm a big
believer that you need to trust your
crazy ideas that when an idea comes to
you you have to go off and do it you
have to teach yourself that you are a
genius therefore you come up with genius
ideas and you need to birth them into
existence because it came to you
therefore it's good at least that's what
I tell myself and here's a quick example
I started a new channel last week
featuring IG lives of different
entrepreneurs one of the things that
frustrated me was that people Your
Heroes people that I love that I look up
to that you look up to are going live on
Instagram every day and the lives
disappear in 24 hours it's just a
function of Instagram is after 24 hours
the lives go away nobody can see them
anymore and I was frustrated for myself
and for you and that all this great
wisdom was being lost but I was also
frustrated for them for the for the
thought leaders for the experts For Your
Heroes that they're creating this
amazing content to help people and then
it just goes away and so I wanted to
help protect their legacy preserve their
wisdom and also have something for you
guys to be able to go back to again and
again and again access to thought
leaders and experts and heroes and so I
thought what if I just started a Channel
with their IG lives and I came up with
the idea on a Friday and then on Friday
we launched
Friday I started with my own live and we
had a live of one other person and I put
them up and we launched a channel set up
the email address set up the banners set
up the channel art set up the playlist
set up the rules and then started
training my team on how to do it and so
now we've got I don't know how many
videos a bunch of videos that have been
put up since we've launched a channel
and and that needs to be the speed at
which you start to move that you get
ideas and you don't sit on them how many
ideas have you had that you've been
sitting on for weeks for months for
years when I when I travel and I meet
different entrepreneurs it it saddens me
so much to see so many people
have had a dream for a decade plus and
still haven't done anything with it the
biggest problem is you're just not
acting on it and so you have to protect
your dream you have to you have to find
a spot that makes you come alive makes
you believe that you can do it but
protecting your dream doesn't mean doing
nothing on your dream right you have to
act even when the people around you
don't understand you think you're crazy
because again you are nuts it's amazing
and you have to embrace your crazy ideas
if you want to change your life change
your outcomes it starts with you
changing your consistent morning routine
you have to figure out what the best
morning routine looks like for you
and that can come from trying on
different people's hats and their
schedules but you have to have something
everybody has something nobody just
wakes up and then hopes that amazing
things happen not people who are
successful a lot of people wake up like
that though a lot of people do wake up
most people wake up and hope something
happens to them hopes they win the
lottery hopes to get the promotion hope
some big customer calls them right we're
just living in a Land of I hope
something big happens to me but I don't
believe it's going to as opposed to
demanding Excellence from yourself every
day and it begins with your morning
routine so how can you do it I'm going
to give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is
figure out what makes you soar so I said
this is the most important part of my
morning routine
what makes you come alive and soar what
makes you feel like the work that you do
matters and you have to show up today so
for me I have to think of a message
every day I think about you guys every
day I I wake up I'm hearing my Toronto
condo it's hard to imagine that 300
million people have seen my videos and
the number doesn't make any sense right
and so it's easy just to wake up and
just continue to live my life me my dogs
my wife and my condo and and just
another okay day right
I have to remind myself that the work
that I do matters I think of a message
and then I share it and I take out my
phone and I post something to Instagram
typically right and that sets me up that
reminds me that what I do matters is
Meaningful I need to demand Excellence
for myself what is it for you maybe it's
creating a piece of content maybe it's
making a video maybe it's watching a
video maybe that maybe this is part of
your morning routine thank you and it
helps you soar right maybe it's doing a
good deed maybe it's meditation or
prayer or walking the dog or playing in
the in the sun like whatever it is what
makes you come alive you have felt it
before you have felt it before you've
had moments in your life where you were
bold confident Unstoppable powerful
where you felt like you could take on
the world right but you felt like your
crazy ideas were possible you felt that
before I know you have the problem is
the problem is it's not consistent
you're not consistently feeling that way
and so you need to reverse engineer
yourself before you worry about taking
on other people's routines and ideas
which are definitely helpful reverse
engineer yourself to figure out when in
your life did you feel the most bold
confident powerful alive and what led to
that happening what led to that
happening and then put that into your
morning routine demand it from yourself
every day right so it could be reading
it could be watching video all the
things I talked about it doesn't matter
you felt it before reverse engineer what
that thing was and then put it into your
morning routine because if you woke up
and you did the thing that made you soar
that made you feel bold Unstoppable
powerful confident every single day holy
cow get ready for a massive change in
what your life looks like over the next
year step number two is ask the high
performance coach question so again I'm
going through all of this stuff with
Brendan I'm going through all this and
and my favorite question
was the one I read
if I was a high performance coach this
is what you should ask every day I like
this if I was a high performance coach
looking at my life from a high level I
would tell myself to remember that
because it's so easy why I love this is
it's so easy to look at other people's
lives and say what needs to be fixed
right you can look at your spouse your
friends your team your parents your
siblings you know your high school mates
whatever you can look at other people
and say that needs to be fixed you got
to go off and do this right you you
become the high performance coach for
other people and what I love about this
is if you're looking at your own life
today as a high performance coach what
would you tell yourself
and then they have one at the end of the
day uh if I was my own high performance
coach I would tell myself this statement
about today so of all the things on here
it's a great format I like that the best
and so I would challenge you for the
next 30 days to ask yourself that simple
question if you were
a high performance coach looking at your
life from a high level you would tell
yourself to remember that what and then
step number three would be which three
people can you model their routine so
Brendan you know he's got his and I'm
I'm modeling this for at least 30 days
I've added you know John Assaraf a
friend of the channel been on a couple
times uh talks about writing down your
goals every day and then and then
touching them right so I'll write down
some goals and then I and then I write
them every day now and I'm touching them
right that's what he does great again
you got to see what's gonna work for you
maybe I do that for 30 days and stop
maybe maybe it's what I do for the rest
of my life I don't know you won't know
until you do it consistently enough so
pick three people who you like pick
three people who you respect who you
look up to say this is the kind of
person that I want to learn from and
then go investigate how they start their
day and then and then try on some of it
right you might love the Rock and he
works out for four hours a day you may
not be able to do that but you could
work out for an hour a day right because
maybe you're doing nothing every day so
it's a good starting point like just get
to the gym and start working out every
day right so pick 3 people who you love
look up to respect admire and then go
research what are their morning routines
and how can you apply one thing from
each of them to see if it works for you
most most people either have no idea who
they are and what they want or they do
but they don't have the courage and
confidence to chase it down if you don't
know who you are and what you want then
that needs to be your immediate priority
that's the single most important
exercise that you can do right now if
you know what you want but you're not
chasing after it having more confidence
in who you are will give you the courage
to chase it down either way I'm going to
give you the answers in this video so
when I first started making videos
I sucked you can go back you can watch
the first one it was April 2009 over 10
years ago I sucked I was nervous I was
shy I was trying to memorize lines I was
sitting down I was in a suit I was
sweating I sucked it was brutal
and making videos
isn't a logical choice for someone like
me I was introverted I still am I was
afraid of being in front of the camera
I'm looking into the lens and the red
light went on and I went blank I was
trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what I
was good at and then put me in in a
situation where I'm making videos that
don't do that that's not for you here's
the thing I liked it
I wasn't good at it but I liked it and
when you like something with enough
effort enough practice most things you
can be great at it
now I'm still on my journey I still have
a long way to go there's still people I
look up to guys like Gary who are
crushing it and say I still have my
journey to get better on but I'm a lot
better than I was when I started
and now I'm off doing keynote speeches
and I'm getting flown out and getting
paid to speak in front of audiences and
I'm growing a Channel with 2 million
subscribers and then these sub channels
on top of them it's crazy
because I was doing a thing that on
paper I wasn't supposed to be good at
but I just loved it and that's where the
self-awareness piece comes in
because you will get an idea to go off
and try something but you'll judge the
idea and you'll say I can't do this
because I don't have X and Y and Z and
I'm not good enough and tall enough and
smart enough for whatever enough right
I'm not enough
and then you play Smile for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you actually chasing
your own version of your life down
because you're thinking about all the
reasons why you're not going to win
instead of the eight while you will so
take it from me a guy who's introverted
afraid of camera shy
doesn't like talking to people
if I can get here so can you on your
dreams why do you get depressed after
you accomplish a goal you celebrate a
goal for five minutes and then you're
sad why is that
goal your goal should not be to climb to
the top of the mountain because the only
spot left is to go down your goal should
be to climb forever you never stop
climbing you're on a mission you're
trying to save the world stop asking
when can I stop you don't you don't want
to you want to climb forever you don't
want to stop not now not ever because
you are on a mission so one of my
biggest fears is the Aging rock star I
look at some of these rock stars who
made it big when they're in their 20s or
30s and then as they get into their 40s
50s sometimes even 60s they're still
playing which is great they're still on
tour which is awesome but what are the
songs that they're singing the songs
that they're singing are still the ones
that they came up with when they're in
their 20s or 30s and I can't imagine
that I can't imagine coming up with a
video in my 20s did I was I on YouTube
in my 20s I was 10 years ago right April
2009 I was on nine wow getting old April
2009 yes April 2009 so it was 29 when my
first video went up great if I'm still
showing that video all the time if I'm
still showing my 40th video then that's
the one that hit I just feel like it's
such a letdown I mean it's great that
you're still on tour it's great that
you're still being asked to get on stage
but to sing the same songs over and over
and over again for me I'm not trying to
judge or say that they suck for me I'm
terrified of that I don't want that to
be me I don't want to think of the video
that I made last year is my best video
ever and all I'm gonna do for the rest
of my life is just play that same video
over and over and over and over again I
want to climb forever
I want to challenge myself to come up
with new stories each time whenever
possible making these kind of videos I
want to always push the envelope I want
to always discover new formats I want to
always look at splitting up my Channel
or bringing them all back together or
launching a course always always
something new always climbing I don't
see it as this Mountaintop there is no
mountain top you're on the staircase and
you're climbing forever and you're never
gonna get to the top you don't want to
get to the top that's that's sadness
that's despair when you've accomplished
everything there is to accomplish you
hate your life that sucks you celebrate
this is what happens for high Achievers
right you celebrate for five minutes
like man we did it and then it's a big
letdown when I crossed 2 million
subscribers on my YouTube channel a
million subscribers I didn't want to
celebrate like because the day-to-day is
a celebration because this is I'd rather
this is a celebration this making this
video right here this is my celebration
moment the process the actual part of
climbing right I'm trying to get better
every single time 6 000 videos later
still going when do I stop I don't I
want to make 6 million videos right my
goal of hitting a billion entrepreneurs
I don't actually want to hit a billion
entrepreneurs
I want to have a goal so big that I
never do it
and so I don't want to be that Asian
rock star I hope that when I'm 95 years
old
I may you know not have my mind totally
there my body might be giving up on me
but I'm hoping I'm hoping that I'm still
trying to push the envelope still trying
to do more do my best and maybe if I get
lazy complacent slow if I start
complaining you catch me complaining
when I'm 95 years old show me this video
back show me this video and say look
look you've become what you said you
didn't want to become right hold me
accountable I think as soon as you stop
growing you're dying
and I think that's why so many people
are unhappy because they've actually
stopped growing a long time ago
and so don't be the Asian rock star I
don't want it for me I don't want it for
you either I feel like I'm always
spending time with myself I'm always
talking to myself I'm always reminding
myself of how awesome I am of uh the
ideas that I have are great and I need
to start acting on them I'm very aware
of my thoughts my feelings my emotions
and whenever it's not feeling right
I switch
and I'll switch on a dime
as soon as as soon as this YouTube
channel stops feeling worth it
not fun anymore wrong energy I'm out and
I'll just leave it behind I move on and
go do something else
I think the same thing of of meditation
I haven't
been able to maintain
and find Value in a meditation practice
because I think there's two there's two
sides of meditation and I only recently
learned the difference
the first is about focus and presence
I'm always focused like I'm almost
always focusing presence I'm I'm 85 in
the moment focused and and 15 thinking
about the future and zero percent
thinking backwards
somebody asked me that question how much
time do you spend past present future in
your day-to-day like zero about the past
that's why I have a poor memory Mark
Drager says I have a poor memory
um I don't I just don't live in the past
so I don't remember most things because
they don't matter to me I don't they
don't apply to me I'm not I'm not
thinking about even even when you ask me
how old I am I have to think about the
year
who cares
I was born in 1980.
May 20th 1980. how was that relevant
because you want to compare your journey
to mine that I've come so this far 39
and you made it this far at 24 or 54 or
whatever I don't know I just don't think
that way I think zero going backwards
and then most of the time it's present
and and a little bit future Forward
Thinking whenever I'm feeling
stuck I'll spend more time with myself
I'll if I feel like I need to go for a
walk I'll go for a walk
it's just paying attention to feelings
another conversation I get into with
Mark constantly is I don't remember what
I said but I remember how I felt
and that's mostly where I live just in
the lands of feelings and constantly
talking to myself you are staying small
because you are afraid you're afraid of
the worst case scenario coming true
losing having no money and being
embarrassed but you know you're capable
of more you know the way that you're
going about doing things right now is
nothing compared to what you're capable
of unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always gonna stay small knowing
that you are capable of more today I'm
going to show you how so one of the
easiest ways to get out of your scarcity
mindset is to go from idea to action as
soon as you get an idea you do something
about it and sometimes that idea often
that idea is going to be too big too
scary too crazy you can't do it who are
you to do this you don't have the money
resources time connections energy right
all of that all of the excuses that come
into your head I like to teach myself
that as soon as I get an idea I go do
something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something the
fact that you look at your calendar
today tomorrow next week and nothing
excites you okay great what can you
shift and it may require wholesale
change it may require you doing some
drastic thing but more likely you could
probably just do one small shift
like just start building momentum just
start doing one little thing every day
to start to train yourself to start to
just push the ball a little bit forward
because often we
think we have to make some giant change
and the only answer is to move to Mexico
and then it never happens because to
move to Mexico takes you however many
you know months and budget and all this
stuff you get stuck in plenty one
instead of doing
what's a small step what's a small tweak
that you can make to today's calendar
to inject more energy into it with
something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate momentum spend five percent of
your time planning strategizing thinking
and 95 of your time doing executing
tactics I call it the 595 rule five
percent of your time thinking planning
strategizing and 95 of your time
actually doing this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs get held up because we're
dreamers we want to change the world
we've got this big mission this big
Vision we've got all these amazing giant
planes and it's so much fun to sit and
think and plan and watch videos and
draft up what our perfect company our
perfect life the perfect world's gonna
look like it's a it's a ton of fun
anytime you get entrepreneurs together
and you start dreaming about the future
right tell me about where you want to go
what you want to build those are really
fun easy exercises for us we love
staying there the problem is none of
that stuff actually happens until you do
something right the perfect world you
want to make the perfect life you want
to build none of that happens until you
actually start doing it think about
working out as an example right you
could you could research all the
exercises you could think about the
beautiful life you're going to have when
you have your six-pack abs but nothing
counts until you actually start working
out until you start running and and
doing your push-ups and doing your
sit-ups and your squats and all of that
stuff five percent of your time should
be picking the plan strategizing the
plan and 95 of the time actually doing
you don't want to be in the same spot a
year from today a month from today heck
even a week from today we don't want to
stay stuck you don't want to be in the
same spot you don't want to be having
the same thoughts to say I wish I could
be further ahead I should be doing
something else like to have the
frustration with yourself your life your
lack of momentum if you don't want to be
stuck in the same spot
one week one month one year from today
the difference is not going to be
different strategies that you come up
with you're you're super smart
you're a smart person and you're doing
this for the right reasons you've got
heart you want to serve
you want to make a difference you want
to feel like what you do matters
the only tweak you have to make
is switching the time you're spending
thinking and pondering and in fear and
strategizing and moving it
to just doing
to just executing to doing one more
so that's a challenge for today
look at your calendar for the rest of
the today for the rest of next week
5.95 five percent anytime planning
thinking strategizing and 95 of your
time doing the biggest problem is a lack
of belief my biggest problem your
biggest problem the world's biggest
problem is that we don't believe in
ourselves enough you could do great
things you could be the Michael Jordan
of something you are literally the
greatest in the world at something but
if you don't actually believe that you
are
then you won't be and people with far
less Talent far less resources and far
less heart than you will win because
they just took action so my biggest
limitation is still a lack of belief
it's still the thing that holds me back
I'm I believe in my ability to do what
I've already done but not to do the next
thing
it's a constant battle and a constant
reminder because you want to grow I want
to grow I want to keep learning I want
to keep getting better and so to get to
that next breakthrough I'm gonna have to
believe in myself to say I can do it
just yesterday I was on Instagram live
with Kevin O'Leary Mr Wonderful Shark
Tank was a super fun interview and the
hour before it
I was just uh totally useless I gave
myself an hour before to prepare to
research to think about what questions I
wanted to ask to think how I'm going to
introduce him when he comes on
I I don't have a connection to Kevin
O'Leary before yesterday I I had the
Good Fortune to meet tons of people and
connect with them but Kevin I haven't
done anything with over the how many
years I've had my YouTube channel it's
crazy so I'm nervous
and in the back of my head is he's a
professional he's it's going to be great
he's not somebody who like yells at his
you know interviewers it's gonna be fine
but in my my heart I'm still I'm still
nervous I'm still worried I'm still uh
anxious that I'm gonna say the wrong
thing ask the wrong question uh not give
a great interview and you know it's over
in in seven minutes is my panic attack
taken over and so that hour before the
interview I was I was completely useless
um I I kind of went over at least 10
times how I was gonna introduce him and
some of my key questions that I was
going to ask him and then I just
basically wasted time I wasn't in the
right mindset to be able to go and do
anything else I couldn't even do
Instagram DMS or emails because I was
too distracted thinking about this thing
that was coming up
but what's the alternative
you know whenever you face those doubts
whenever you face those fears the
alternative is saying no the alternative
is oh I I can't do it I'm I'm busy find
some excuse right Evan of 10 years ago
probably would have backed out of it
would have found some reason why I
couldn't have done it I'm busy uh you
know find some some find some reason
I want to teach myself that I do scary
things that I do difficult things that I
lean into the thing if I don't believe
in myself enough then I have to go do
the thing to show myself that I believe
in myself you can say all day long I
believe in myself I believe in myself I
believe but if you don't do the thing
you won't believe in yourself
and so you do it scared you do it when
it's hard you do it when it's difficult
even if I go on the live and just say
the wrong thing to Kevin and insult him
or he leaves or something happens the
fact that I showed up with with with a
positive intention with the goal to try
to make this a great interview is enough
for me to Pat myself on the back and say
I did it now the interview ended up
going great at least I thought I thought
it went well we had a good conversation
we talked about his new business I made
a new connection you know follows me on
Instagram it was it was a fun time and
logically you might be watching and
thinking of well of course it's gonna
work out you've done all these
interviews and logically to myself it's
the same thing of course it's gonna work
out I've done all these interviews and
with harder people to talk to than Kevin
O'Leary
but in the moment when the superior
talking the logic isn't enough to get
you through it at least for me it's it's
the boom boom boom test that my heart's
beating boom boom boom boom boom I'm
nervous I'm scared I have to do it
that's how you start building confidence
belief self-respect by doing difficult
things now I've got a three-step process
I'm going to walk you through to help
you get more self-belief number one is
be surrounded by it be surrounded by the
things that make you believe in yourself
more this is so critical because chances
are the people around you aren't
encouraging you to be more aren't
pushing you saying you're capable of so
much more a lot of people have either
haters around them people telling them
that you're never gonna make it be safe
be practical go get this safe job over
here you can't go do that or people who
might
have empathy might have some kind of
understanding but they don't know how to
push you to do greater things and so you
have to be surrounded by the people who
make you feel like more as possible this
is so critical it's so important it's
why I make this YouTube channel I want
you to start your day with confidence
and belief so if this channel does it
for you great hey every day I'm making
videos if not on this channel they've
got lots of other channels also making
content but if it's not me then it's
somebody else if it's Dean's Channel or
Dean's books or Dean's podcast that
makes you feel bold confident a lie
powerful then then be surrounded by it
as much as possible have it as a part of
your regular schedule have it in your
environment look at my environment here
look at the people on the wall behind me
I walk into here and these people make
me believe in myself more from Steve
Jobs to AP giannini to my parents Howard
child's Kanye West these people make me
believe in myself more from from the
cell phone background that I have and I
load it up it says it says remember your
intention
remember your intention yeah you can see
it hey you can see it it works remember
your intention as a reminder reminder
for myself my desktop background the
clothes that I wear right I feel like
I'm Batman going to work I feel like I'm
a superhero going to work to try to
change the world for the better every
time I put this on now that might seem
crazy to you that might seem stupid
childish ridiculous awesome go do you
but think about it from your office
environment to you know the screens on
your phone and computer to what you wear
it impacts your psychology it impacts
your self-confidence so you want to be
around it as much as possible physical
environment plus online environment for
the the music you listen to the podcast
the videos you're watching to every day
inject that belief into yourself step
number two is fix your morning routine
most people well most people don't have
a morning routine so most of America
doesn't have a morning routine but if
you're watching this video you probably
have some kind of morning routine most
people wake up like an accident you
probably wake up and have a morning
routine and so your friends and family
people who look at you they might even
be in awe of your morning routine and
say how how do you accomplish so much
and how you stick to that morning
routine you're the one that people are
going to for advice on morning routines
but your morning routine is likely still
broken you want the most important part
of a morning routine is it's not
brushing your teeth it's not uh you know
meditation it's not even watching one of
these an espresso videos as much as that
breaks my heart
the thing that's most important in the
morning routine is do you get the
feeling of belief of Unstoppable
confidence of boldness when you finish
it
too many people are just checking the
boxes too many people are saying well
okay I'm gonna wake up I'm gonna brush
my teeth I'm gonna read a book I'm going
to work out I'm gonna X great check
check check check check check check
perfect you checked all the boxes you
did it
but you don't feel bold
you don't have confidence you don't feel
the belief why well one of two reasons
one either your morning routine is
broken and you actually have to inject
something in you have to actually watch
that video or make that call or do that
meditation or say that prayer or
whatever the thing is you have to add
something into your morning routine to
get the confidence
or two your morning routine actually is
okay you're just not doing it with
intention so remember my cell phone
screen here right remember your
intention remember mine this is how do I
there we go remember your intention this
is a constant reminder for myself
to remember my intention your morning
routine
you might have all the right pieces to
it and maybe watching a video is the
thing that gets you feeling fired up and
ready to go and have that belief but if
you're watching a video while you're
doing something else if you're watching
a video while you're brushing your teeth
or while you're planning out your day or
while you're making your lunch or
something else and you've only got half
your brain on it and you're not actually
too focused on it then great check
you watch the video you can check it off
your morning list but you don't feel the
feeling and if you don't feel the
feeling if you don't feel bold powerful
Unstoppable confident coming out of your
morning routine then you need to
immediately fix your morning routine for
tomorrow it's one of the single greatest
things that you can do because if you
woke up and did the thing that made you
feel belief confidence boldness every
day if that's how you started your day
you actually felt that every day your
life is gonna look dramatically
different when you're from today I
guarantee fix your morning routine and
step number three is pass the boom boom
boom test and the boom boom boom test is
when your heart's beating boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom that's a
sign to go that's a sign to do that's a
sign of your your beliefs in yourself
being questioned when I had Kevin
O'Leary coming up on my show boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom right even
having Dean on my show
I had Dean not too long ago on my show
and now I know Dean better we've hung
out in Puerto Rico he's been on a couple
times already we've spent some time
together so uh he's he's a closer friend
than Kevin O'Leary who I didn't know
before now the last time I had Dean on
was to promote his book but I couldn't
bring him in for more than a couple
seconds Instagram I bring him in and he
would crash and so I try to bring him in
and then we'd crash again so try and I
tried like four or five times to try to
bring him in and he's sitting there live
and it just keeps crashing and it felt
so terrible it's like all my my worst
nightmare is coming true right like it
didn't work out oh my gosh I feel so bad
I'm letting him down and letting my
audience Down live it just felt terrible
and so in the back of my head is oh my
gosh remember the last time I tried to
have Dean on
the the Fiasco that happened and so boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom I don't
want it to happen again this time but
not letting the boom boom boom this is
just your fear talking right this is a
lack of belief talking it's a lack of
belief that it's gonna go well this time
you can't let that hold you back from
actually doing the thing and quite often
what happens is you feel the boom boom
boom boom boom right it's going like
this
but then your brain will find some
reason why you can't do it your brain
will talk you down from doing the thing
it'll find a really logical smart reason
because you won't believe a stupid
reason a really smart reason why you
can't do the thing and so you don't but
really you're just afraid and so this
helps you catch it when you feel the
boom boom boom it's going like this your
heart's beating I'm scared I'm I'm doing
that thing I'm doing that thing I'm
going to reward myself for the effort
whether it ends up working out or not
because I do scary things and so do yeah
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there don't spend money till you're
making money teach yourself that at the
beginning of your Venture you are not
going to spend your money until you're
actually making money what are you gonna
do you're gonna invest your heart your
hustle your energy